des tweets en signe d'excusé une vidéo
des plus explicative
les agents de la monusco la mission de
l'organisation des nations unies en
république démocratique du congo sont
dans le viseur de la population
congolaise
samedi un chauffeur a été interpellé
durement par des casques bleus chinois
après qu'il a renversé en voiture l'un
de ces derniers une vidéo très commentée
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui a poussé
la chef de la monusco à prendre des
mesures
la chef de la monusco bintou keita
exprime son indignation concernant la
vidéo qui circule montrant
l'interpellation d'un civil par des
militaires de la monusco a qu à vue mais
elle a ordonné une enquête immédiate
pour établir les faits et prendra les
mesures appropriées rétablir les faits
et redorer dans le même temps l'image
d'une monusco critiqué ces dernières
semaines pour sa passivité
les manifestations se multiplient en
effet pour dénoncer les massacres de
civils
cible présumée des combattants des
forces démocratiques alliées un
sentiment d'insécurité et
d'incompréhension plein dans les plus
grandes villes notamment celles de l'est
du pays demande aux autorités de mettre
en marche pour que nous puissions voir
que la monusco puissent rentrer chez eux
normal les gens à béni et nous a tenté
des citoyens nous puissions rester dans
les sécurité et que la monusco rester là
sans pour autant intervenir une pression
accentuée par un récent appel à la grève
générale lancé à beni depuis le 5 avril
les écoles sont fermées les taxis-motos
urbains sont à l'arrêt à l'instar des
boutiques des principaux boulevards de
cette ville de deux cent trente mille
habitants samedi à kinshasa la capitale
une marche également mené par les
opposants au président pour exiger le
retour à la paix a été dispersée sur
ordre du gouverneur de la ville